é boa tarde bom vamos falar um pouquinho
aqui não é um resultado específico de
pesquisa muito mais idéias e propostas
para discussão futura então queria falar
um pouquinho sobre a educação que o
brasil precisa né na nossa visão a o
primeiro conceito a qual é a nossa visão
de brasil né então conhece brasil que
está falando
quando a gente olha aí foi na área e é
na população brasil é uma grande
potência o quinto maior país do mundo
se a gente olha em pib e economia também
nós somos uma potência bastante
respeitado o sétimo maior pib do mundo
só que quando a gente começa a olhar por
exemplo a educação a gente é o 56º
sétimo de 65
a gente olha o pib per capita ou seja o
quanto o país gera de riqueza por pessoa
nesse país a gente é 61º e se a gente
olhar para o mais importante que a
qualidade de vida a gente é o 79º nesse
contexto é esse brasil que eu quero
discutir um pouquinho a educação é
porque a gente precisa de melhor
educação
gente eu não vi bastante a questão de
que agora o brasil é um país de classe c
mas o que é a classe c a classe c aquela
ali a classe c vive na favela
será que é isso que a gente tem que
comemorar não é isso que a gente quer
para o futuro do brasil é um país onde
está super satisfeito porque a gente tem
pessoas que moram na favela e têm
condição de consumir é isso que é o
sonho da gente né eu acho que é muito
pouco a gente tem que querer muito mais
que isso a gente tem que discutir não é
é porque a indústria porque a tecnologia
do brasil não cresce
pelo contrário em cole a indústria se
vocês olharem ali aquela participação da
indústria na economia do brasil
a participação da indústria na economia
no brasil atualmente é menor do que era
antes de juscelino kubischek a indústria
no brasil vem diminuindo desde meados
dos anos 80 e é uma queda praticamente
constante o que gera gente da classe b
ou na classe a
indústria ou a área de tecnologia área
de uti por exemplo não é é pra isso a
gente precisa de pessoas capacitadas ao
longo dessa última eleição eu escutei
uma pessoa fazer um comentário falei
gente eu não acredito num comentário que
eu tô ouvindo falando assim esse
político tem conexões com a indústria
por isso ele nunca vai investir em
educação
essa frase não faz o menor sentido a
quem fala isso não sabe o que a
indústria no mundo essa crise da nossa
indústria justamente porque a nossa
educação está ruim
a indústria precisa de profissionais
qualificados então se realmente um
político qualquer se tem conexões com a
indústria de que a indústria não tenho a
menor dúvida que ele é investir muito em
educação porque ainda a indústria quer
melhor educação a indústria precisa de
melhor educação aquela queda é por causa
da educação
a gente não vai conseguir competir no
mundo com a educação um porque a gente
quer uma vida melhor primeiro por causa
desses três aí a mônica uma lista e
mateus
tá eu quero que o mundo seja melhor
quero mais e melhor por causa deles
ah eu quero uma vida melhor para os
alunos com que o trabalho não é com as
pessoas que trabalham comigo lá no meu
laboratório
eu acho que a gente quer buscar uma vida
melhor para o brasil e isso eu não tenho
a menor dúvida que o único jeito é
tentar uma vida melhor para todos os
brasileiros é através da educação
o que a gente precisa na educação
uma coisa que eu acho que é importante
eu sinto isso não só como pesquisador
mas como pai não é o pai que está
levando seus filhos na escola e que era
discutido bastante com coordenadores
sobre o que é aquela escola que ela
oferece aquela escola
eu sinto que nossa escola está invertida
a nossa escola hoje está se preocupando
muito pouco com conteúdos
ela não se preocupa tanto com a escrever
ela não se preocupa tanto com fazer
conta com ciência geografia e ela se
preocupa com muita coisa que deveria ser
cobrado dos pais e não da escola
então é eu vejo por exemplo a minha
filha voltando aqui que seria uma tal
disciplina a eu aprendi a sentir e
pensar foi legal tá bom em matemática a
pai ensina porque eu aprendi na escola
tá então tem uma coisa que está estranho
nessa escola
ela fica lá não sei quantas horas por
semana e sim ensinar a sentir ea pensar
ea criança volta para casa e o pai
precisa ensinar ela a fazer conta porque
a escola não deu conta de fazer isso ou
eu tive até uma conversa uma vez como a
coordenadora que falou 'não você tem que
entender que a escola hoje nessa
conteúdo tem que ensinar valores olhei
pra casa foi desculpa não quero que os
ensina valores
quem tem que ensinar valores sou eu são
meus filhos
os valores que quem tem que passar para
ele sou eu eu quero que os ensina
matemática e português deixa aqui valor
de ensino
então eu sinto que a escola brasileira
hoje ela está invertida ela está fazendo
as coisas que os pais deveriam ser
cobrados para fazer e não está fazendo
tanto que ela existe para fazer como na
educação
bom eu não posso negar minha origem tá
então para quem não conhece aquelas
fotografias toda a professora que
conhece por exemplo não é primeiro o
piaget o piaget foi orientador do papel
da ti né
tive o prazer de conviver com ele trocar
algumas idéias com ele o papa que
orientou o valente com quem eu tenho
prazer de conviver até hoje no ied que
orientou a sicília que orientou aquela
figurinha lá né que está junto comigo
quer dizer que sofreu
tá é então eu sou da linha do do piaget
tô aqui né é um bisneto do piaget tá
gosto acho legal o construtivismo tem
muita coisa interessante é muito
interessante para motivar o aprendizado
é muito interessante você inspirar a
busca por conhecimento para você fazer
as pessoas nem os alunos jovens procurar
traz atrás de conhecimento mas a gente
também não pode esquecer que a história
tem mil ante a escola tem mil anos de
escola ao longo de mil anos aprendeu
muito do que eu sinta que parece que o
brasil jogou fora todo mundo esquece
tudo e agora é só de piaget pra cá é um
desperdício de conhecimento e coisas que
funcionavam
então é cartilha kátia se você falar em
qualquer escola fala de cartilha é
melhor falar do demônio
ela é completamente abominada eu falando
sério a partir dessas pessoas era uma
cara você assustada assustado gente
tática funcionou como o avô cartilha
funciona com meus pais cartilha
funcionou muito bem comigo e minhas
filhas não tiveram cartilha estavam
tendo dificuldade com algumas coisas eu
fui na bíblia na livraria e comprei a
cartilha que eu usei fãs graças a deus
ainda vende e adivinha as minhas filhas
voltavam da escola
pegava aquela cadeira e ficava tarde
inteira se divertindo com a cartilha
afinal qual é o problema dessa cartilha
se as crianças gostam dela se funcionam
tá ou tabuada não pode decorar a tabuada
é porque não pode alguém consegue
imaginar alguém fazer contas sem saber
taborda decor
não tem como você não dá um passo além
se você não der o básico a gente precisa
do básico você sabe é da tabuada
primeiro armas de cor é chato quem disse
que decorar chato
as crianças adoram decoração criança
assiste o mesmo desenho animado 50 vezes
para decorar o que ele falou
a gente não vai colocar os nossos
valores das crianças ao longo de mil
anos a escola aprendeu que decorar a
tabuada funciona e agora há 30 anos
atrás alguém descobriu um que não nada a
ver e adivinha nossa escola continua
piorando a gente tem aí que a gente pode
usar da escola bom a nossa geração atual
geração que está na escola hoje a
geração que nasceu com tecnologia ea
gente tá dando pra ele não dá pra ver
muito linda mas aquela escola lá até
pior no brasil uma boa parte das quais
não tem educação não têm energia
elétrica
é uma porcentagem grande é pior que
aquela é é a gente tem que usar a
tecnologia porque a criança que está na
escola e ver o que ela vê no mundo real
dela no dia a dia dela não é tão para
motivar a usar coisas como game ficação
tá então aqui a esquerda foi uma
experiência que eu tive é na faculdade
de tecnologia na de ensinado em fora
programação da forma completamente
diferente
damos robôs em forma vamos fazer uma
disputa entre vocês
foi fantástico eu tinha dez alunos
matriculados você olhar para tinha 20
alunos na sala falou é que você tá
fazendo aqui
também quero brincar então a pessoa ia
lacen
matriculada porque achava aquilo legal a
gente tem que usar tecnologia que deixa
essas coisas legal legais para
contextualizar do lado de lá estão vendo
uma ferramenta que é feita para crianças
tá de você criar aplicações em
smartphone android que controla o
robozinho no chão tá então imagina com
aquela criança ver que aquele smartphone
que que a mãe dela usa que o pai dela
usa dá pra controlar o robozinho a
motivação que estudar e o principal que
acha computacional fim o pensamento
computacional que é o que se coloca
muito hoje nós temos que usar a
informática na educação não porque a
gente quer que as crianças sejam
programadores no futuro mas porque a
gente quer que as crianças aprendam a
pensar e quem sabe trabalhar computador
aprende a pensar ah mas a escola não
pode ser uma só usa a tecnologia ela tem
que apresentar os problemas é a
apresentar os problemas da excessiva
conexão usar o celular demais a smart
phone mas tem várias questões
problemáticas até que se na concentração
e foco que você precisa tirar o celular
da frente para conseguir você precisa
mostrar a importância de saber mais do
que o básico na então eu fiz uma
pesquisa aqui e caiu
tá eu fiz uma pesquisa que na unicamp
entre alunos de engenharia do último ano
neste ano no meio deste ano e fez a
seguinte pergunta quem é michel temer 70
por cento não sabia o que era michel
temer e de seus engenheiros de último
ano da unicamp z
a gente tá numa época que o conhecimento
está muito superficial você vê o título
e clica e click click no le tá então uma
agenda que os professores da única os
alunos da unicamp não sabem que é o vice
presidente da república é tão gentis a
valorizar 1 contra o contato a interação
outras coisas que têm que sair daqui já
pra isso é é antes que seja expulso só
que esse treco agora desmontou vamos na
mão aqui não vai sair a rapidinho só pra
fechar a escola a gente tem que pensar
uma escola que liberte que valoriza a
curiosidade que a crise a criatividade
que dê espaço para libertar para a
experimentação e que seja lá e todo
sentido que não impõe nenhum tipo de
valor nem
religioso nem político e ideológico a
escola tem que deixar a criança pensar
agora na mata também a escola não pode
ter medo disciplinar é então eu vejo
isso ela não está errado gente a gente
tem que ensinar que tem que respeitar
professores têm que respeitar regras né
que ciências forenses emérito ninguém
chega a lugar nenhum e que sem esses
valores numa nação progride aclimação de
progredir se você não valoriza as
pessoas expostas pessoas que têm mérito
na escola tem que ensinar isso é o
brasil precisa da gente tá é é a gente
precisa se colocar como responsável pela
educação parar de colocar a culpa no
governo nos professores nos
pesquisadores todo mundo tem que fazer a
sua parte o máximo possível porque só
assim que o brasil vai melhorar
não é porque os jovens do brasil tem
potencial e eu queria passar um vídeo
para fechar aqui o desafio jovem
engenheiro é um projeto que a gente
conduz aqui no tanque para jovens alunos
a internet para divulgar é a
participação de crianças da mina e nível
médio
incentivá los a gostar de tecnologia
isso aí foi um grupo de 4 34 jovens do
ensino médio fizeram sozinhos ao longo
de uma semana quando a gente propôs um
desafio então se você tem tudo que eles
fizeram em uma semana a integrando
várias tecnologias da integrando é
física empregando um pouco de filme que
pegando é a parte importador sejam para
o final a gente dá motivação certa a
gente incentiva os jovens a irem mais
longe eles vão foram seus projetos como
esse na final todos eles muito bom
tá sendo que a gente é única porque
precisou foi organizar isso através do
facebook e é incentivá los através de
uma promoção de uma divulgação e de uma
pequena premiação
então eles fazem coisas fantásticas
quando a gente dá é potencial pra eles
bom é isso que eu queria falar né a
minha ideia vamos juntos fazer o bahia
brasil é o país do presente né não
largasse do brasil o país do futuro a ok
obrigado